you don't s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour l'épisode single till dawn
la dernière fois c'était très éprouvant
on passe tout de suite et la suite après
le précédemment c'était quoi çà çà çà
pourrait être plein de choses
après ce petit arrête voici notre billet
vert le monde des esprits
non non non j'ai eu assez les chocottes
pour cette nuit c'est clair dans la
boule de cristal je vois un pain chaud
alors amusez vous bien
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] c'est pas vrai mais une
personne en particulier retient toute
notre attention mais nous ignorons tout
son emploi du temps il y a toujours un
ancien hôpital psychiatrique dans la
montagne
se pourrait-il qu'il s'y cache chapitre
5 et froid à 6h jusqu'à l'aube
ok c'est la suite [ __ ] je suis tout
excité donc lui il essaie de lui
poursuit le psychopathe en fait micheal
à des bulls quoi il ya des loups monga
environs du sanatorium
le mec il a des loups ok parfait pouvait
pas marcher pas des petits caniches quoi
objectifs en cours trouver un moyen
d'entrer dans le bâtiment ok donc c'est
bien ce que j'avais dit il faut qu'on
aille par la petite trappe qui est je ne
sais plus où sur la droite je crois ouah
c'est tellement flippant monga sa part
en chais pas alan wake quoi à tous les
coups c'est fermé c'est pas fermer ta je
m'attendais pas sans déconner sur quoi
on va tomber dès à cette porte bien
[ __ ] [ __ ] y'a quoi là le mec qui
donne deux ou à manger aux p'tits loups
ces désordres de chasse locked voilà on
a bien vu il me faudra une fois impasse
il me faut un pass chapelle security pas
ce week end
ok on va trouver le chat pallisco et y
passent à la ola olhao je peux monter ou
pas faut que je fasse tout le tour
hockey à mon avis il est juste là où
dans la table on va faire le tour ça
c'est une morgue mais c'est parfait
franchement c'est exactement ce que je
voulais c'est quoi un de ces gars a
carrément essayer de me mordent je vais
en rendre compte au docteur bauwen olala
6 janvier 1952 d'accord donc apparemment
il ya une histoire il ya eu un
effondrement est à douze mineurs ont été
bloqués sous des caillous pendant plus
de trois jours
forte heureusement les mineurs sont en
moins bonne santé et leurs propos
cohérents psychologiquement après avoir
été enfermés pendant 23 jours à ses 23
jours parfaits traitement raison l'âge
nature fragile nous avons fermé elle a
du sanatorium des évaluations
psychologiques prendront place
rapidement oh là là le psychopathe c'est
l'un de ces mecs là qui est resté à 23
jours sous terre c'est ça ok d'accord ok
vous ils ont voulu aider des mecs en
gros ça n'interviendra donc je suppute
que l'un de ces psychopathes
c'est l'un de ceux qui restent et sous
terre pendant longtemps et s'il est
resté sous la terre
c'est parce que la maison de josh et où
des parents de josh
quand elle a été construite y est ça a
créé des éboulements voit la théorie de
merde tiers du peloton
ah on l'apprend on l'a lève on à la
machette du tueur calais le fuck
[ __ ] on va pas se défendre remarque
c'est bon ça que se passe à aa
je me fais caca culotte aulas le scot de
squelettes comment ça va holla holla
with the boys voilà on a fait une petite
intervention musicale dans ce let's play
pour se rassurer
il ya des pouilles il est la ouate on
parlait de zombies justement c'est quoi
le délire
ouah c'est ça qu'il a retenus mais non
n'importe quoi à fonction politique est
quand ça arrive politique est non non je
vais perdre un doigt mais non mon gars
j'aurais pas dû regarder schüco les gars
je suis désolé mais faut qu'on soit des
guerriers soit on ouvre le piégeur soit
on ampute on va amputer [ __ ] je sais
pas il n'arrivera pas assez impossible
d'ouvrir un piège à ours il n'y arrivera
pas c'est pas possible
et si son but les doigts et risque de
tomber dans les pommes ouvrir le
piégeage paypal en [ __ ] c'est trop dur
voilà bah oui voilà avec la machette
tulle où mon gars voilà ça passe ça
passe ça passe ça va j'ai compris à les
ampute les doigts c'est moi j'ai compris
allez on y va
allez allez michael était un bonhomme
d'un bonhomme d'un bonhomme inquiète ça
va aller tout seul tout seul tout seul
tout seul tout seul c'est le sèchement
ouais je sais oui
m
je
à
[Musique]
as tu pourras plus jamais faire plaisir
à jesse de la même manière c'est ça la
donc là un peu désabusé inaction ça a
changé la trappe de l'histoire quoi mais
c'était ça où il ya le look y arriver il
allait buter quoi elle est chère tir tir
tiers oui c'est une ce qu'on appelle une
morgue
oui oui il va y avoir un cadavre dont me
dis pas que c'est l'une des deux soeurs
non je me suis enfin il ya un mot il ya
un moyen d'étiquettes l'identification
médicale d'urgence
non nicolas beau and adult and
identification 24 février 1952 attaqué
par des tenues lacérations mortel à la
gorge mais non c'était le docteur c'est
la note qu'on a lu tout à l'heure qui
parlait dé 23 gallas et c'était crise
par le docteur bauwen ans je me chie
dessus où je me situe va y avoir quoi là
y'a encore l'oeil accord mon gars
j'espère juste qu'il ya pas se lever
quoi
c'est pas l'une des deux soeurs c'est
pas l'une des deux soeurs ok la
surenchère ya le badge ans le voilà le
badge il est là le badge de sécurité
trop bien aller mais la carte là allez
allez ça s'ouvre et là bas mon se couper
le bras comme ça parfait et dans cette
pièce là bas qu'est ce qu'il y a des
choses encore plus qu'à voilà les tâches
[ __ ] enfin ra ra je me disais bien
qu'on allait trouver un jour à l étage
[ __ ] [ __ ] c'est beaucoup trop fort
cours cours pour cour pourquoi aller q
tu es occupé occupé
tu t'es un coucou coucou monga cddp ils
sont déchaînés ils mangent et alain
jardel
ok c'est bien c'est bien michael c'est
bien
ok ça c'est fait oui ok bonjour mon ami
le loup je suis seul dans un endroit
très glauque
je m'en vais parce est petit escalier à
et je me tire à à eau
au début je n'ai pas frappé donc donc
c'est mon pote j'ai trop bien fait
d'avoir peur d'études fillette au en
vous souvenez le message qu'ils ont dit
au début parfois c'est mieux de ne rien
faire
j'ai trop bien fait je n'ai pas fait
exprès j'adore les animaux vous voyez je
passais une vidéo de toujours john bost
pour rien moi je vous le dire c'est que
à la baisse jusqu'aux pas tu vas
peut-être trouver des indices non il ya
un pistolet là bas ah je vais tirer la
table à toi la chance quoi la voix
habilité pour que le bureau tombe comme
ça et que ça glisse tard je m'en fous je
vais pas me plaindre je m'en fous ça
m'arrange maintenant j'ai un chien un
gun bientôt j'aurai des billets à
toucher de l'argent c'est nickel à 1 10
allez on tire donc sur dota revolver non
voilà allez on braque le cadenas ça
c'est une prémonition qu'on a eu aussi
un jeu pas si vous souvenez
renault l'a pas chaud et voilà on n'a
pas de nous il va se réveiller attaché à
la chaîne comme ça tout nu [ __ ] voilà
on l'avait vu dans le générique du jeu
qui possèdent ces caméras
le tueur c'est un jeu pour eux c'est un
jeu quoi je peux plus retourner du coup
c'est ça voilà c'est fermé merci importe
qu ils n'ont pas tort [ __ ] seuls 14 et
marvel excusez moi ou elle a h au louis
je dis pas non hop là c'est bon ça a dit
se trouver ash ouais mais c'est surtout
une arme pour la situation actuelle 2 h
15 la porte
tu veux attendre une minute il va nous
entendre si on commence à tout casser a
pas le choix et à une meilleure idée ben
si c'est quoi
regarde une fenêtre super match je peux
à peine faire passer mon baume à lèvres
à travers 6 3 et drôle ça moi j'ai plus
envie de le faire un petit peu en
infiltration pour pas faire de bruit pas
tirer l'autre alors on va et des
milliers à passer allez je passerai pas
mais toi aussi tu es malade tu veux
faire passer par ce tout petit trou a
renchéri cui à la balle prière par
contre d'un coup quand on dit que c'est
un talent n'y a pas de souci on y va
allez allez me dit allez met les attend
mais yakaré attendu formalité comme elle
qu en largeur le trouver dans tu te
démerdes voilà tu trouves la [ __ ] de
boigne et tu te tais merci [ __ ] bon
boulot web
j'étais super tout a été retourné c'est
leur affaire c'est non celui qui n'ont
ils s'engueulent ils sont deux c un plan
c ça ok c'est un plan alors on est là
ici c'est une antenne radio ici c'est là
qu'elle vole car là on est ok voilà
l'antenne radio c'est charmant
ouais c'est flippant ouais voilà la tour
de guet c'est la question la catégorie
qui vient gratter quelque chose enfin ce
serait aussi oui allez on y va sûrement
aller matte nous devons trouver cette
radio à mes yeux je te dis j'approuve
tube i'm ont brouillé être en désaccord
rentrons ou à khe s'il nous faut cette
radio bon du coup je du coup j'ai un
doute vu qu'ils nous donnent le choix
est-ce que c'est pas mieux de rentrer
pour aider san qui est seul ou entre
gens sérieux m
ça pourrait marcher mais je pense je
pense qu'on devrait peut-être retourner
au charbon va pas se diviser
tous voila voila [ __ ] on s'entend bien
match aller on se casse on va t'on
d'antenne pour il a quoi quoi quoi
oui c'est une tentative
qu'est ce que tu fais j'ai nous sortent
ici monsieur l'intello pas tellement à
l'époque
hop là elle a pris la petite échelle à
lons casse toi on veut carrément partir
d'ici
c'est vrai ouais j'ai deux buts et est
passé devant pour protéger allez on
arrive à l'arrivée et boum
ok c'est parti direction la tour de guet
on y va aller un os un totem un nom ça
présage pas que du bon [ __ ] à 10 mois
un totem chance te plaît s'il te plaît
ueli maurer ferme terre bavois [ __ ]
que dans le peuple
c'est génial ça ah là là j'allais
repartir mais si les matchs se sent pas
bon j'en sais rien desserte
c'est quoi ça sert le travail vers quoi
non mais plus les bilans au jeu pas la
fin de match va la faire de mal
c'est la foi alors ce connard de psy
oh
[Musique]
il s'en fout il est parti
mais hélas rien fait qu'est ce que vous
faites encore il aurait pu la défoncer
quoi blague
voilà leur vieille blague non non non
pitié non [ __ ] on est seul comme ça là
avec un des côtés se faisaient plus
qu'un décolleté on va lui tout est on là
ça va complètement l'excité le postulat
va nous défoncer oh là là haut il a pris
ses fringues c'est le tueur qui a fait
ça il l'a pas fait pour rien et va se
faire un sommet
[Musique]
j'ai pas dit sonné j'ai dit à sommer
ross ça m'a fait peur
icloud torch est cool mais moi ça va me
sauver c'est avec la honte à nous sauver
moi j'ai envie qu'il reste en vie sam
j'aime bien moi je dis ça il ya le
psychopathe qui arrive
j'apprécie vraiment pas votre silence
bande de cons ça lui chante tu me
chercher je ne pense qu'aux futurs
officiers
tu verras seulement sûr que je vous fait
penser à trets
[Applaudissements]
je vais te venu dix secondes courir je
cours je cours je cours je cours
oh merde [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
merde joie de jeter bas mais ça aurait
rien fait sauter sauter il va trouver
soul il est pas con il est pas con way
j'ai bien fait j'en étais sûr j'ai bien
fait c'était la bonne idée
non content d'être cachés pour qu'on
suit cash il va trouver c'est sûr cours
cache-toi plus loin voilà j'ai bien fait
je le savais oh non c'est fermé je
renverse plutôt que de forcer comme ça
maintenant
[Musique]
tu t'es vraiment un cutter c'est sûr aux
basiques un g14 data on a réussi non on
va le retrouver
il connaît l'endroit par coeur les mecs
il sait parfaitement où il ya quoi au
nom se cache et courir court court court
se cacher ça sert à ça sert à rien c'est
une mauvaise idée il connaît l'endroit
parcage part de ce principe il va tout
le temps de trouver tout le temps tout
en l'air
ok j'aurais dû me cacher j'aurais dû me
cacher j'aurais dû me cachais pas le psy
alors c'était stimulant non bien joué
c'était pas mal ouais
toutes ces heures passées à découvrir
l'origine de vos peurs et vous vous en
servir à tort votre peur des ventes de
la solitude
vous en avez fait un outil contre des
personnes que vous désirez tourmenté
cela on va les dix la paire eur aud
donc c'est nous le clown c'est nous les
méchants en fait c'est ça le mec qui
était qui consulter chez le psy c'est le
clown
ar je sens que dans le prochain épisode
tout s'éclaircira comme le ciel un mois
de juillet c'était nul windows phone 7 5
et vidéo sur un type d'offre j'espère
que ça vous a plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo que nos
habitudes
il s'est passé mille trucs c'est juste
incroyable de partout il ya eu des morts
du sang des dates du stress le jour
permet bon eh bien écoutez on s'entend
très bientôt pour le sixième épisode le
sixième chapitre
au total il ya dix chapitres ce qui veut
dire qu on est à la moitié du jeu ou
simplement bravo c'est un petit
applaudissements j'avoue merci d'avoir
gardé de chanter monde et à très vite
pour la suite bis